- On today's show, Jamie Lee
Curtis, Sigourney Weaver,
Nev Campbell, Sarah Michelle
Gellar, and me Mark Ellis.
And while it's true
only one of those names
will be appearing on this show,
the four others will be duking it out
for sisterhood survival supremacy,
and they know a thing
or two about surviving.
All four are considered Final Girls,
a term coined for a leading lady
who makes it through a horror thriller
with their life intact
(screaming)
- So you'll forgive us
if the occasional ending
of "Alien 3" or "Buffy the
Vampire Slayer" season five
is up here.
By and large, if you're a movie villain
or a creature of cinema, or
even a spider in their house,
I don't like your odds.
Not against these gals
who've combined to conquer
the likes of murderous
siblings, clingy aliens,
undead armies, and in a shocking twist,
their own boyfriend?
- What's the matter, Sidney?
You look like you've seen a ghost.
- Rendering a decision on who wins
in this all time battle is me,
the guy who's never been to outer space
or ran over a fishermen
or had his brother tried to stab him.
I've never even been called on the phone
and been asked the scary movie trivia.
And I think I do well at that one.
Come on, Ghostface, step up.
You got my number.
- [Ghostface] Do you want to die?
- Here's how we'll determine a winner.
Round one, box office.
Round two, Tomatometer/audience score.
Round three, enemies.
And then I'll do a wild card round
that Sigourney Weaver hopes will involve
who's slept the farthest above the covers.
Carried away in Bill Murray?
No, we don't have that?
It's from "Ghostbusters."
I'm afraid of all the ghosts,
but Jamie Lee, Nev,
Sigourney, and Sarah Michelle,
they say bring it on, so
I say, let's get it on.
- Come on!
- Round one, box office.
Nothing makes for a
night out at the movies
quite like a good, scary flick.
So for all purposes of
this and all rounds,
we're going to keep each
competitor's film resume
to movies that exist somewhere
in the horror, thriller, sci-fi range.
Sorry, "Cruel Intentions."
I tried to squeeze you in.
"True Eyes," I love you, but no.
"Heartbreakers?"
Well, Jennifer Love Hewitt was in
"I Know What You Did Last Summer,"
so there I'm being told to move along.
- So are you going to kill me,
or are we just making small talk?
- You, the dear viewer whose taxes
don't in any way pay my salary,
may be thinking that this
round has been unfair
for Sarah Michelle Gellar,
as she was preoccupied
making eight great seasons
of "Buffy the Vampire Slayer"
on TV while her counterparts
were making hit movies.
But to that, I'd simply say...
- Scooby, dooby, doo.
- "Scooby-Doo" counts as
a horror sci-fi movie.
Whether it's a real ghoul
or you're just freaked out
by a talking dog, those flicks hauled in
a combined $370 million at the box office,
beefing up Sarah's
overall total box office
to over $900 million
for a per-flick average
of $136 million.
One of the movies helping
her out is "Scream 2,"
which also stars Nev Campbell.
She had a great 1996, as both
"The Craft" and "Scream,"
the original one, were released.
And since then, her combined movies
have gone on to accumulate
$695 billion total
for a per-film average of $139 million.
Her most boffo box office has been thanks
to her starring role as Sidney Prescott
in the "Scream" franchise.
To date, the four movies have
totaled 644 million bucks.
Yes, it's a great ensemble cast,
but without Nev being the glue
that keeps Woodsboro together,
we ain't getting a series of films
that rival the popularity
of the previous movies
they give a wink and nod to.
- You're starting to sound like
some Wes Carpenter flick or something.
- Sorry Tatum, I think you
might mean John Carpenter,
the fellow who directed Jamie Lee Curtis
and her first starring role
opposite looming shape, Michael Myers.
Still one of the most
profitable movies of all time,
1978's "Halloween" made $188 million
off a production budget that was less than
what it cost one "X-Men"
film to feed Hugh Jackman
all that Wolverine protein.
And while Jamie didn't appear
in every "Halloween" sequel,
she made the ones in which
she did return count.
As in counting moolah.
Her "Halloween" films have
total $587 million overall,
but those aren't her only
scare-centric titles.
Jamie Lee Curtis also carried
movies like "Prom Night,"
"The Fog," and "Terror
Train" to financial success.
Although her average box office per film
is the lowest of our four
stars at $76 million per movie.
Again, apologies to her
and Billy Ray Valentine,
but I can't toss "Trading Places" in here.
- Don't say it, Louie.
- So now Sigourney Weaver
steps up to the plate.
Regarded as a pioneer in
the realm of bad-ass women
taking charge and saving the
day at the talking pictures,
and for good reason.
Remember how predators
struggled battling aliens?
Yeah, they should have watched
more Ellen Ripley game film.
Her marquee franchise "Alien"
has grossed a total of $730 million
across her four movies so far.
And then when we toss in the likes of
the "Ghostbusters" franchise
and roles and thrillers like
"Copycat" and "The Village,"
this round is an easy
win for Dana Barrett.
But hey, even if we stick with
just the "Alien" pictures,
her per-film average still
ranks at the top of this heap
at $156 million per outing.
Okay, I might've tossed in her cameo
in "Cabin in the Woods" too.
That elevator scene is bonkers.
(dramatic music)
- Sigourney wins round number one,
and she's up one to nothing,
to nothing, to nothing.
- You got some moves on you, girl.
- Round two, Tomatometer/audience score.
Okay, ladies, let's see who
can prevent Ellen Ripley
from going up two to nothing.
Yes, audiences love seeing
a good chest bursting alien
even if it doesn't sing and dance.
But does the Tomatometer approve
of Sigourney Weaver's
outer space exploits?
Yep.
Eh, kinda.
"Alien" and "Aliens" are
all-time sci-fi stalwarts,
registering at 98 and 97% respectively.
But before you go
crowing, "Game over, man,"
the punchline is that
her last two entries,
"Alien 3" and "Alien
Resurrection" are both rotten.
And along with the certified
fresh "Cabin in the Woods,"
that gets her average to 77%.
Still considerably above her competition,
but movies like
"Ghostbusters 2," "Copycat"
and especially the rotten
"The Village" at 42%
anchor her average down further.
- What nonsense are you saying?
- Nev Campbell is showing up
to play big time in this round
as she's the only other lady
with a fresh average for
her thrillers notching 64%.
Her high watermarks are
for "Scream 2" at 82%,
and the original "Scream" at 79%.
And while "Scream 3" did go rotten,
"Scream 4" came back to
fresh territory at 60% even.
For completionists, "The Craft"
is so close to fresh, 55%,
we're one good spell away.
Maybe we get a sequel?
(gasping)
Sarah, Michelle Gellar
has a rotten average
of her film rolls at 33%.
"The Grudge 2," "The Return,"
both "Scooby Doo" movies,
They all punch in at 30% or lower.
But here comes Buffy.
If we toss in her seasons
of fresh television,
the Vampire Slayer and Angel
are at 82 and 88% respectively,
but it only gets her to treading
water with a 40% average.
That's okay, she's doing it a
voice in the new He-Man show,
so SMG still has the power.
It's all up to Jamie Lee Curtis here.
And while her per film average is only 54%
on the Tomatometer, what impresses me
is how well she does outside
of her "Halloween" wheelhouse.
"The Fog" and "Road Games" are fresh,
alongside her best "Halloween" hits.
And speaking of those spooky movies,
Jamie Lee Curtis can boast four films
in the top 10 of all
film catalogs combined,
which begs the question, what
about the audience score?
Jamie Lee Curtis has five
of the top 10 in that list
as Rotten Tomatometer
movies like "Halloween 2"
make the leap from 30% to a fresh 63%,
according to the audience.
- Why won't he die?
- So while Sigourney Weaver
certainly has an argument
with her first two "Alien" movies,
and Nev Campbell is
within shouting distance,
Laurie Strode is getting
the W in round number two,
which she probably hates,
because it's only going to
draw more attention to her
and thus get on the
radar of Michael Myers.
Mike, if you're watching,
and let's face it,
what else did you have
in your iCalendar today?
Don't stab the messenger.
I met Jamie Lee Curtis once
in a Quizno's parking lot.
She was very nice.
Oh, we're still doing the show.
It's one to one to nothing to nothing.
- Do you know that I pray every
night that he would escape?
- What the hell do you do that for?
- So I can kill him.
- Round three, enemies.
When it comes to the first two rounds,
Sigourney and Jamie Lee
had a sizable head start
as their careers kicked into
high gear in the late 70s.
Nev and Sarah Michelle didn't
emerge as stars until the 90s.
But you know who doesn't
care about that timeline?
- Evil.
- All right, I get it, you're evil.
Do we have to chat about it all day?
- As Sidney and the "Scream" franchise,
Nev Campbell had to not only tangle
with a mysterious killer
who, through the four films,
had multiple identities
underneath the classic
ghost face mask, that wasn't
the only competition she faced.
By the time we meet her in high school,
she's already haunted by the
tragic death of her mother
and those bratty kids at
her educational institution
didn't exactly form a safe
space to nurture her recovery.
- How do you gut someone?
- You take a knife, and you slit 'em
from the groin to sternum.
- There was the constant
press hounding as well,
which only intensified once
Gale Weathers made claims
that the man they found
guilty of killing Sid's mom
may actually be innocent.
That alone is enough to make anyone weary,
and when we talked to the
fact that her boyfriend,
the Johnny Depp adjacent Skeet Ulrich,
was half of the villainous
gangsters trying to kill her.
It's pretty rough for Sid.
The three sequels further
traumatized Sidney,
as she had to watch a
sizeable chunk of her friends
get sliced and diced, well, into chunks.
If she only had a mentor that could have
lent some friendly advice
as to how to battle a shape
that won't stop like Laurie Strode.
Her sometimes bro Michael broke bad early,
and by the time we see his
first person perspective
in smooth panaglide,
he's already descended
into a dead eyed, stone
cold, lead-footed monster.
And while I'd take
Ghostface over Michael Myers
at the NFL combine, the slow lumbering OG
eventually arrived at his
destination, Murdertown.
Which if you're Hannibal Lecter
is the equivalent of Flavortown.
(hissing)
Laurie and Sidney both had to tangle with
a specific masked entity.
Sidney could never sleep
because some other baddy
always took up the mantle.
Laurie couldn't get any shuteye
because killing Michael is tougher than
prying a xenomorph off your face.
What's that?
What's a xenomorph?
Ellen Ripley knows the answer.
She's seen them attack her pals,
threaten her freshly shaved head.
Hell, she's even housed
one inside her womb.
And the problem with aliens
is that they just keep wanting
to make babies and procreate
and kill anything that doesn't
have two drooly mouths.
And while I think we
can all consider Ellen
the ultimate survivor,
she ultimately chose
to sacrifice herself rather
than allow the company
to harvest what's going
on inside her body.
So Jamie Lee and Nev had
to endure multiple battles
with humanish villains, and
Ellen had to play in a way game
in deep space to encounter her nemesis.
It's a tough call between these three.
But back on Earth, none
of them had to deal with
the constant threat of the undead armies
that thrive on centuries of
blood-sucking day napping power.
That job belonged to Buffy.
- I don't know, think of something cool,
tell him I said it.
- If you're known as the Vampire Slayer,
you're probably good at your job.
But this isn't a dream gig
like being a pro athlete
or an internet host.
This was a lifelong task thrown at
Sarah Michelle Gellar's
trademark character
when she, like Sidney,
was still finding herself
in high school.
Our expert researcher, Mark Hoffmeyer,
noted that she's killed
hundreds of vampires in her day.
And when you go off on so
many anti-garlic mongers
that Hoffmeyer loses count,
you're doing something right.
- Did I get it?
Did I get it?
- Then Buffy pulled an Ellen Ripley
and sacrificed herself to save the world
at the end of season five.
Don't worry, she came back in season six
and picked up right where she left off.
So even though she didn't
make it through "Scream 2"
or "The Grudge 2," or "I Know
What You Did Last Summer,"
she put up a hell of a fight
against the Gordon's fisherman
and that whole battling the
hoards of undead bloodsuckers
in between cheer practice thing?
Yeah, that's enough to get
her a win in round three.
- Shop and hang out and go to school
and save the world from
unspeakable demons.
You know, I want to do girly stuff.
- We got a doozy of a contest now.
Can Nev even the score at one apiece,
or will someone else emerge
with an outright win?
We're about to find out.
Because now it's time
for the wild card round,
iconic moments.
Saving all of us mere mortals
from the likes of outer space creatures,
supernatural entities, and asshole boys
is a really tough job.
And it's impossible to pull off
without creating a
motherload of iconic moments
along the way.
- This is the moment when
the supposedly dead killer
comes back to life for one last scare.
(screaming)
- Not in my movie.
- These four ladies combined game tape
would make the vault at NFL films blush.
And it kicks off with 40 years' worth
of Laurie versus Michael masterpieces
that played out at the
legendary Soldier Field,
home of the Bears.
I'm sorry, the whole NFL
thing kind of carried me away.
But they were from Illinois,
so it kind of fits.
My favorite moment
between these two is when
they see each other through the glass.
Over multiple films, a
version of this scene
has played out in a variety of ways
when a mere door separates good
from evil, right from wrong,
a hardened survivalist
against a masked lunatic.
Laurie is the only one in these flicks
who stood up to Michael
and lived to tell the tale.
And in "Halloween Water," sorry, that,
"Halloween H2O," she ups
the ante by saving your kid.
Hey look, folks, it's Josh
Hartnett and his girlfriend.
Hey look, folks, it's Michelle Williams.
Then she refuses to escape with them.
Not now, not tonight, not ever.
It's time to finish the game.
She locks the gate, grabs an
ax, and says, "Let's duel."
Which kind of makes her Aaron Burr,
and Mikey is the guy from the $10 bill.
(screaming)
Let's not overlook more recent history
when Laurie gets America's
least favorite power walker
just where she wants it,
locked up in the basement,
burning his way into Hell.
And although the release of that sequel,
"Halloween Kills," has
been pushed back a year,
I can go ahead and count a scene
from that teaser as iconic.
Laurie gets a brief moment of relief
followed by the terror of
hearing fire engine sirens
coming to put out the flames.
I salute you, firefighters,
but please let this house burn.
- Let it burn!
Let it burn!
- Sometimes vampires can be burned alive.
Or dead, is it?
But they don't often fall for the whole
getting the paper in the morning
and forgetting that
the sun is out routine.
No, you usually gotta end their reign
with a stake right through the heart,
and Buffy earned the moniker
of Vampire Slayer for a reason.
Ladies and gentlemen, enjoy
(glass crashing)
(screaming)
- You know very well, you eat this late,
you're gonna get heartburn.
Get it?
Heartburn?
- I'm super sorry, I
forgot to warn any vampires
to avert their eyes.
But if it makes y'all feel any better,
you're not the only one
Sarah Michelle Gellar
has pounded into dust.
- Now who's the damsel in distress?
- Me?
- Straight up.
(triumphant music)
- In the "Scooby Doo" movies,
she ain't no damsel in distress,
and as much as anyone else,
it's Daphne that is the
most fearless of the bunch.
And in "The Grudge," the paranormal terror
is even more real.
That flick might feature one of the most
memorable horror movie shower scenes
not starring Jamie Lee Curtis's mom.
(dramatic music)
(gasping)
Gellar is such a bad ass,
she even plays her heart out
in a losing effort.
It's a three-part slug fest
that Captain Hook has to endure
before Sarah is finally felled
in "I Know What You Did Last Summer."
And just for sheer fright
fest entertainment,
the "Scream 2" death,
that's one for the ages.
(dramatic music)
- Please, no!
(screaming)
But if it's "Screamed"
vengeance she seeks,
get Sidney Prescott's number
out of the school directory.
The headshot on Stu at
the end of the original
is A grade superstar material.
Not to mention when she
mimics Laurie Strode
and has to take out her
half-brother in "Scream 3."
By the time I got to "Scream 4,"
most folks walked in assuming Ghostface
was finally going to get his woman,
but no one told that to Nev.
Jill, her niece, becomes
the latest in the pantheon
of masked Woodsboro
creeps to meet her demise
at the hands of Sidney.
- You forgot the first
rule of remakes, Jill.
Don't fuck with the original.
- It's a tough call for who has
the bestest, mostest
iconic moments so far,
but, what's that?
Good God, that's Alan Ripley's music.
Okay, maybe it's not
actual notes or chords,
but Sigourney certainly
loves the rhythmic sound
of an airlock.
She's utilized it to her advantage
in both "Alien" and "Aliens."
In the first adventure,
she was so hell bent
on taking care of this thing
that she locks the crew out.
That's commitment to the job.
Then "Aliens" gave us
one of the greatest lines
in the history of sci-fi thriller cinema.
- Get away from her, you bitch.
- That load lifter is so
cool, and I have yet to see it
under the tree on Christmas morning.
Santa, if you're watching,
I'm going to keep asking.
- Ho ho ho.
- What separates Sigourney's
marquee character from the pack
is her unselfishness.
She embraces the role of
being a motherly savior,
not just to Newt or briefly an alien,
but to all of us earthlings.
She is the mom that comforts our globe
by choosing to kill an
alien by sacrificing herself
rather than risk this
thing heading to our world.
It's a tough call here.
As we're looking at decades
of movie and television entertainment,
but I'm giving this round,
and thus the win, to Sigourney Weaver.
Not only is she the archetype
of what a tough protagonist looks like,
you also want no part of
her on the basketball court.
Get home safe and take
those skills to the Rucker.
(dramatic music)
What I admire about all
of our contestants today
is their extreme ability to save our ass
while enduring and intense character art.
Their journeys would make Joseph Campbell
add another volume to "The
Hero with a Thousand Faces."
Through all her seasons of TV greatness,
Buffy's entire worldview changed.
She went from optimist or pessimist
and learned to care about others so much
that at one point, it cost her her life.
Twice.
- The power!
- Laurie Strode did her best
to maintain a normal life,
even though the fear of
Michael's imminent return linger.
She was always ready, eternally prepared,
and when the moments arrived,
she came through in the clutch.
- Happy Halloween, Michael
- Maybe more than anyone else,
Nev Campbell's Sidney Prescott typifies
the Final Girl concept.
And by the end of "Scream 4,"
we realized that there's
only one unstoppable force
in that franchise, her.
And yes, kids, I think she's
coming back for "Scream 5."
- I don't know about you, but
I feel a whole lot better.
- But my winner today is Sigourney Weaver
on the strength of intergalactic
martyr, Ellen Ripley.
She wasn't born ready to end
it all for our greater good,
but thank goodness she got there.
You've gotta think that even the predators
have an honorary spot in their
hall of fame for Ms. Ripley.
But this is just one fellow's opinion.
And now the pressure
is on you, dear viewer.
Chances are at least one of these ladies
has saved you without you even knowing it.
So thank them by casting your vote
in the comment section below,
and defend your choice.
I read them all because
I'm not busy saving Earth.
I'm just a fan watching
these movies and shows
and getting inspired to revisit
their amazing cinematic journeys.
I think I'll do that tonight.
Turn the lights off,
fire up the subwoofer,
put some Jiffy Pop on the stove.
Oh wait, Drew, is that,
is that not a good idea?
(upbeat rock music)